my arm isn't there yet but it will be in
a moment
see how many techniques do you want me
to show you from the same footwork the
same theory i can show it to you but
you are the only one who can grasp it
uh well we've got ken again
so any walmart uh style like you know we
do a lot of weapons and the the belief
is it improves your tidings it improves
your body but apart from hasso
can any i'm saying it's like a woman
aggie can anybody don't love it can
anybody actually tell me where they see
a lot of taijitsu with the weapons you
don't i'd like you to hold it
okay
so it's this way up right
he said she used to go
it's strong here it's strong here
[Music]
it's not strong here
and see how he's turning
now
some of you said this before i see that
angle sword's the wrong way up we know
and it's there for a purpose the wrong
way
what does one arm look like
an upside down sword
so if i work down here
or here
but if i work here with the fingertip
going around the sword but but because
the sword is a stiff item a fixed item i
can't just go in
but that's what i should take from the
sword i should say
since he actually
he actually went round the circle didn't
he
and then when it got to a certain point
with this person
he went in now i know you don't see the
whole you don't see the whole picture
of this
but you see the start of it and that's
where
it's not a party piece this
it's to show you that that
movement
is
the righto dory
movement
so if i do it like that i still can't go
in halfway through the circle
so i teach it like this so you've got
room
to drop it right out here this circle
right out here this circle
and then
it teaches you techniques
so so and what i discovered when i was
searching for this was
i was going into quick because i wanted
to do the technique
so so the more you can make this
circumference
the longer you can make it
and then what happens i'll tell you the
next stage what happens the next thing
what happens is you start making this
thing you go
oh i can feel it now i can feel it now
and then you you're too low and you go i
can't get in now
see because she was daydreaming enjoying
it so much
you've gone past the point
so there's a point that you're gonna
you're gonna have to look out for you're
gonna have to go
right so now my eyes are open
i'm just about in line with his elbow
that means i can get under it
when i move in
so here it's a good place for him to
block me
but
he's busy blocking this while i'm busy
down here
with my
hips
i'm not current that's what you're
feeling next i'm not i'm not actually
turning out of the man i see you're
feeling a bit of the block there
okay
i use i use the hips
all right so we've got that i'd like um
not to use a block but think of your arm
as that pain and try and develop it